please thank you very much madam
president
ladies and gentlemen today's general
office can securely confirm that Croatia
has taken the EU helm at the crucial
juncture the new institutional cycle is
in a full swing and tomorrow the new
Commission a lot of its first annual
work program in the program we will set
out the most important initiatives the
Commission intends to take in its first
year and of course it will require a
team effort by all institutions to
deliver on them I know we can count on
the Croatian presidency the presidency
priorities are well chosen a lot of them
will fall on the General Affairs come so
the next smart annual financial
perspective that will be discussed in a
minute over the lunch and we know that
mff is essential for the functioning of
our union in the face of profound
changes especially climate and digital
revolutions after all a budget is a
political program in numbers we have
full confidence in the Presidency's
effort to steal forward the remaining
work on sectoral files then the second
very important issue which will be
covered by the General Affairs Council
is the fact that the start of this
decade will be marked by the departure
of the United Kingdom after its 47 years
long
EU membership breaks it is a loss for us
all but as we move into the next phase
meaning the opening of the negotiations
for the new partnership we will need to
maintain our unity this was the case
until now thirdly I would say that we
are saddened to see a member state
leaving there is no better time to
dedicate attention to the prospect of
the new members coming into our union
therefore the Commission will present
its contribution for a new methodology
in the coming weeks
and these rhymes well with a special
attention that Croatia wants to pay to
enlargement policy also with an EU
Western Balkan summit in Zagreb and of
course the first ever conference on the
future of Europe that was the main point
our agenda today I'm sure it will be at
several occasion discussed among the
ministers for European offers I think
that you are familiar with the
Commission's contribution to the
conference which was adopted last week
therefore only three brief remarks also
as a reflection on today's discussion
first I think also the debate has
clearly proven that it is vital that all
three institutions are in sync and that
we swiftly adopt the joint declaration
on the conference modalities once the
council will agree its position this
will be the priority for both the
vice-president dubravka Sousa and myself
to make sure that we as a three
institutions together with the European
Parliament can go forward second the
partnership cannot stop there we can
only succeed if national parliaments
regional and local actors are on board
and the conference must be a truly
pan-european exercise reaching every
corner of Europe thirdly we are not
starting from scratch but building on
many citizens dialogues which we already
organized in the past but this time a
feedback mechanism I'm sure will be a
true game changer as it should ensure
that the ideas expressed in this
discussion will also pave the way for
the concrete recommendations for the
future of the European action the
Commission is ready to take into account
people's feedback in the setting of the
legislative agenda and in my area I will
make sure that will also feed the debate
of the Europeans by our strategic
foresight reports to conclude I am
looking forward to working with the
Croatian presidency as well as we do
personally Andrea and I know that this
is the case for all my colleagues
commissioner and as this is the first
presidency for your country for Croatia
I am convinced it'll make the entire
country very proud thank you very much
thank you mr. vice president